don't you have a job that's a fair  question i worked in sales for the past  year and a half and i was just like  miserable i hated it but when i was  working that job i would create content  for the company they didn't pay me to do  it i just did it for fun i really liked  it and some of those videos did pretty  well on linkedin like couple thousand  views nothing crazy but like you know  pretty decent so that made me realize  that content creation and media that's  what i really liked doing then my tick  tock started to take off so i made a  plan to leave i saved enough money so i  could live for like six months to a year  applied to go back to school which i got  accepted i start in january and now my  goal is just to build my brand and find  a part-time job that i can do virtually  while i'm in school